besonderes augenmerk dabei sollten wir
auf kelly ann conway richten hier sehen
wir noch einmal den inneren kreis in der
mitte hop xfx die engste vertraute des
us-präsidenten die ist bisher auch
erstaunlich lange an seiner seite
ausgehalten hat verglichen mit all den
menschen deren karrieren im weißen haus
nur sehr kurz waren hob iks ist
vermutlich sozusagen das epizentrum
dieses ausbruchs im team trump und wir
sehen kreieren konnten wohin
faszinierende gestalt in der frühen
phase seine sprecherin dann als
sprecherin ausgetauscht worden aber
immer noch eine der engsten beraterin
und kelly ann conway und auch das zeigt
ein bisschen in welch unglaublicher
polit globalen politik kommen wir gerade
leben kelly ann conway ist nun positiv
getestet und kelly ann conway hat eine
tochter die sich auf tik tok dann mit
ihrer positiv getesteten mutter
beschäftigt hat wir wollen uns das
einmal ganz kurz anschauen das war noch
bevor überhaupt rauskommen dass die
mutter positives hat die tochter dieses
bemerkenswerte video auf tik tok
gepostet rassistisch
also wenn deine mutter wusste schwenkow
im haus müsse wenn donald trump gerade
mit corona positiv getestet worden dass
sie hat sie sozusagen geäußert sie hat
sie geortet
in breitestem breitestem teenie akzent
sozusagen auf der plattform der chinesin
ausgerechnet also social video-plattform
der chinesin auf tik tok hat dann die
tochter von kelly und conway darüber
fast gespottet dass ihre dass ihre
mutter im in der oberen etage des hauses
vor sich hin rostet warum gespottet auch
das wirklich an jan soap opera qualität
kaum zu überbieten
die tochter von kelly in corvey clark
gerade gegen ihre eigenen eltern um den
eltern sozusagen das sorgerecht zu
entziehen weil da in der familie
offenbar nicht alles so ganz glücklich
läuft was es in vielen familien gibt
aber da war schon in den letzten monaten
immer streit und jetzt hat sie quasi
ihre mutter die bei diesem top event war
geordnet auch das hätte sich stichwort
drehbuchautor man sich für hollywood
nicht besser ausdenken können und wir
haben auch noch ein zweites video
vorliegen aus dem ein bisschen höher
vorgeht was die tochter von kelly m con
way vom chef ihrer mutter und der
politik dieser regierung hält und das
wollen wir uns jetzt auch noch einmal
anschauen ich glaube es handelt sich
ebenfalls um 1 tick tock video
[Musik]
märz deutliche worte die sie da findet
ohne was zu sagen aber trotzdem sagt sie
sehr viel man kann sich vorstellen dass
die stimmung im hause nicht so gut
gerade mehr nachrichten und breaking
news nur bei bate schau dich hier das
nächste video an und vergiss nicht zu
abonnieren